let's talk a little bit about the u.s
customary units of weight so the one
that's most typically used is the pound
especially for things at kind of a human
scale and to understand what a pound is
most playing balls are roughly about a
pound so for example a soccer ball
my best attempt to draw a soccer ball
so let's say this is a soccer ball right
over here and i'm not and then of course
it has some type of pattern on it so you
could imagine a soccer ball is about is
about a pound so it's roughly one pound
and a pound will often have be
short-handed with this lb
period right over here so it's about a
pound of football an american football
is also
a little under a little under a pound
but we could say it is about a pound
just so we get a sense of what a pound
just so we get a sense of what a pound
actually represents now if you want to
go to scales smaller than a pound you
would think about using the ounce
you would
think about using
the ounce
and the relation between the ounce and
the pound when we're thinking when we're
thinking about weight
is that
one pound let me write this one pound
one pound is equal to 16 ounces
is equal to 16 ounces or another way of
thinking is that isn't thinking about it
is that a one ounce is equal to 1 16
of
a pound and if you want to visualize
things that weigh about an ounce you can
imagine a small box of matches
weigh about an ounce
so a small box of matches might weigh
about an ounce
maybe a a small
double a battery
would a would weigh
about an ounce but that gives you a
sense of it so if you were to take 16 of
these together they would be um they
would be about the weight of a soccer
ball 16 of these things together they
would be about they would be about the
weight of a soccer ball or a football
now if we want to think about weights
that are larger than a pound then we
would go to the ton
we would go to
the ton
and a ton is equal to one ton
is equal to two thousand
two thousand
pounds and you have to be a little bit
careful with the ton we're talking about
the u.s customary units and this is
where we're talking about 2000 pounds
but when we're talking on a more
international level this is sometimes
called the short ton there's also a long
ton there's also the metric ton but here
we're talking about u.s customary units
which is the short term so one ton is 2
000 pounds and to get a sense of
something that weighs 2 000 pounds or to
get a sense of what 2 000 pounds is like
or what might what might be measured in
tons a car is a good example
your average mid-size sedan your average
mid-sized sedan would weigh
about a little under to a little over
two tons so a little under to a little
over to a little over
4 000 pounds if we're talking about a
small van or minivans or vans or trucks
we're thinking we're going to be larger
than two tons and if you think about
smaller cars you're thinking it's going
to be probably around 3 000 pounds it's
going to be less than 2 tons so a car
a car
is a car is going to be approximately
2
2 tons so hopefully that gives you a
sense of
of what units you would use in the u.s
customary system for different scales of
weights